I wondered if I could show a few
photographs that I took just today
during a short walk around a quaint
Portland Southwest Portland neighborhood
of signs on poles so this is a it's a
pretty white neighborhood as Portland is
pretty gentrified I think it's a little
commercial area it's Multnomah village
and within about a five block area
I took cut 20 photographs and some of
them some of these are not high quality
I'm going to show 14 or so here 14 I
think here and I'd love us to just talk
about them and then at the end it's a
good segue to talk about black lives
matter so Zach if you want to show so
these are again these are posters that I
saw in a in about five block radius in
Southwest Portland today on June 23rd
2020 and for those who are who will be
listening and not seeing this one says
black lives matter hands up don't shoot
color is not a crime okay that makes
sense and you've got people drawn it's
you know the artwork is is good it's
interesting and people in masks behind
it so that looks that looks like an
honorable representation of what black
lives matter is claiming to be it's a
warm image of this protest absolutely
let's see next next one so sorry about
the lighting here it's super bright and
hot out here in Portland today a few
simple truths that I believe this one
says no one should live in fear murder
is wrong no matter what uniform you wear
and justice shouldn't be something we
have to demand
I'll be done marching when I see a
change this too I find completely
honorable and it was actually it was
this was in the window of a metal arts
shop and I thought it was actually going
to be like a book art shop printmaking
and maybe they have letterpress in there
but this looks like a handmade
letterpress sign with completely
honorable sentiments you know all of
these things anyone who can't get behind
no one should live in fear or murder is
wrong no matter what uniform you wear
I'm that actually indicates a problem
in the head of that person if they think
people should be living in fear now now
we are moving into slightly more
ideological already memed sentiments no
justice no peace which is one of the
things you'll hear chanted black lives
matter
this is folded so you it is actually
spelled correctly there with now
familiar black lives fists but also you
know the hands reaching up I can imagine
this you know people reaching for
justice and and trying to do right so so
can I just point out yeah no telling
what was on the artists mind but that
fist and those hands are not a match
those hands are comparatively dainty and
that fist is robust mm-hmm I wonder if
there's not a subtle message about what
they wrongly call a lie ship here no
that's interesting yeah so the the
anthropological term would be sort of
gray style versus robust forms in which
the gray style forms are the allies and
the robust which is say the stronger and
physically more dominant forms are the
are the powerful ones yeah and of course
one of the things about being a human is
that we have moved farther away from
might making right
in general we have we have been able to
do that through our complex sociality
and frankly through our laws and our
morals yes
alliances make strong but then that
raises all sorts of questions about
these alliances which are created
through this process that we talked
about at the beginning where the only
right answer is yes I agree and then
once you agree you'll get your orders
that's right okay next one
we cannot allow their voices to go
unheard anymore this is a handwritten
sign hash tag justice for all hash tag
BLM hash tag silence is violence
allusion to what you were suggesting
earlier and then up at the top
hashtag amplified melon ated voices
which that's not that's not a thing and
that's dehumanizing again right this
brown and black bodies
rope that is emerging is dehumanizing as
is the idea of Melanie did voices on the
other hand we cannot allow their voices
to go and hurt anymore
you know I object to the anymore the
same way I object to the second a in
mega actually it's exactly the same
thing make America great let's do it
make America great for everyone because
it wasn't great for everyone at any
point in the past and this is a point
you have made repeatedly we cannot allow
their voices to go and hurt for sure we
everyone needs to be able to have a
voice in a democracy but anymore look at
the history in this country over it you
know since the civil rights movement and
and ask yourself who actually is being
disappeared by the mainstream media and
the idea that there are whole
demographics whose voices aren't heard
and that this is the moment that we must
change that is it is not reflective of
what we have the reality we've been
living it's not it's really not
reflective and I like your point about
the analogy here to maggot there's
something psychological about the
statement in which you are already
rooting for the statement at the point
you get to the twist at the end that
forces you to agree to something that
isn't true
exactly um and it's really I think you
have to you have to read through the
whole thing before you say anything
about what you think about it and then
we all do this thing that I'm doing
right now nodding along like I'm gonna
not along to you because if you end up
saying something crazy eh you don't tend
to and you know in my estimation but
also I can let me like you know what
actually no but you know we're being
asked to sign onto these things yes we
can't allow their voices to go unheard
period yes make America great period
yeah and it you know the risk of
alienating many many people I have been
paying attention to Tucker Carlson's a
little essays that he puts on nightly
off late and I must say there's
something 25% of each one that feels
like it's pandering to a particular
constituency but there's a good 75% of
them that is right on target and I
strikes me as
white patriotic and open-minded and you
know he pointed out the other night we
have elected a black president right and
we can try to parse that any way we want
but at some level the idea that black
voices are unheard is just simply
inconsistent with the history that we
all know and the same thing was true at
Evergreen white supremacy is alive and
well at Evergreen it's everywhere we had
a black president for how long of the
color of the car yes right and so in any
case the point for the entire duration
of the black president of the United
States less purse was president of the
college and for a time before and after
that as well right and and you know this
claim erupted full force at the place
where we were dedicating a building to
that president and you know he was there
to speak and he was interrupted in order
to challenge white supremacy it's just
it's preposterous the juxtaposition is
really stark but at the point that you
say something like well I can't sign on
to that statement it's like AHA knew it
white fragility great you know exactly
all right next next sign racism and
police violence happen here it says in
the past month alone italics George
Floyd Hamid Borman a butcher these names
almond Arbor II Brianna Taylor and Tony
McDade have been brutally murdered by
police officers this could happen any
day in our community we cannot remain
silent so how can I help donate your
money in time to contact your local reps
and demand accountability three talk
sense into racist family members and
friends again some of the sentiments
here all right we this could happen in
our community
maybe racism and police violence happen
here what is the here this is in a
neighborhood in a city where there has
been a killing of a black man at the
hands of the police officers in the last
couple of years which is quite
contentious with regard to what the
specifics were and it seems pretty clear
to everyone that there was there was
confusion and perhaps intent on the part
of the young man who was killed these
things didn't all happen here so here we
have the the gaming
of the language and the Flyers where you
get you get an immediate emotional
response racism and police violence
happen here right here are the names of
the people right
those aren't here and that's not to say
that we aren't all living in a society
that does have racism and police
violence but this is this is beginning
to melt into actual lies I think so
and it also dovetails with some things
that we've talked about earlier the the
strangeness of the protests at Yale
where Nicholas Christakis you know one
of the most decent people that we've
ever encountered is challenged as is as
if he is vile by people who are claiming
oppression who are highly privileged all
right the whole thing just cannot be
made to add up if you take it at face
value we are seeing protests spread from
the u.s. to other places we've started
to get contacts from our friends in
Britain who are watching a protest it
doesn't make any sense because the
relationship between black Europeans and
white Europeans is not an exact mirror
for what goes on in the u.s. they're
quite different this is palpable to us
when we have traveled there and yet the
Internet is causing this wave of
sentiment I guess maybe I put it this
way because the mechanism of
transmission is contagion right it's not
persuasion it's contagion and because
it's contagious because it's built to be
contagious the point is well what's to
stop it from being contagious across an
ocean if we are as close as our screens
to what's taking place over there so the
little traps that you know cause us to
you know chase our tails here in North
America are also causing people who
happen to speak the same language to be
chasing their tails in the British Isles
even if it doesn't apply and so this is
a huge danger and at some point I think
we need to talk about
people have a an old model of what to
fear and because you would imagine that
revolution would grow from a central
point in some way but in fact what it's
done is it's made a demographic
transition where a lot of nonsense was
fed into a lot of kids heads in college
and those people then went into
institutions it's like Oh guess what
sleeper cell inside of every institution
of a certain size and a certain size is
like above 20 people yeah and the
nonsense was not just fed into kids
heads in college it's in the k-12
schools i husband for a while because
the schools of Ed have been have been
captured for at least you know for at
least a decade or more yeah as you know
there's a good essay by a friend of ours
on this which rather than butcher at the
title I will find it and speak to
directly another time but yeah even even
worse that children not just college
students who are who are children in
many regards yet but actual children are
being indoctrinated children who
inherently by the nature of children
have no mechanism to protect against
what they are being told is the truth
right that we are supposed to protect
them from dangerous falsehoods at that
age so they're open to things that
adults will tell them and we are now our
schools of EDS are now feeding this mind
virus into these young heads with no
defense mechanism and it only gets worse
from there that's right okay next next
poster bad apples spoil the bunch demand
that the Multnomah County Commissioner
divest money from racist policing
initiatives and jails and redirect funds
for housing mental health services
schools and more so let me just show the
next two as well because they're all in
this sort of defund the police okay bit
I want to come back to the Apple stop
okay well so let me show the next two
and then all two hundred and forty five
million one hundred sixty nine thousand
eight hundred and four dollars for
policing it says no thank you
we'd rather have accessible food
programs Cara not cops PDX okay on the
next one in the same vein 245 million
one hundred sixty nine thousand eight
hundred four dollars for police in
question mark no thank you
we'd rather have free public
transportation at Kerr not cops PD acts
okay go for it um yeah well I just think
something you know $30 for a family
dinner we'd rather have an Xbox you know
it's like you swapping these things in
here a do you know what that amount is K
are you in a position to evaluate how
reasonable that amount is and also just
the idea of we'd rather have this than
that and my point would be you want to
talk about the problem with policing
fully up for an adult conversation about
even throwing out the entire model and
replacing it with something that works
better but you want to tell me you want
to start by removing the police you're
telling me you don't understand the
first thing about what civilization is
and how it runs and you imagine somehow
that whatever was before civilization
you can return to and you haven't
stopped to think about the density that
we live at you don't understand why you
may be decrying violence that shouldn't
be there and it shouldn't be there but
you have no idea how much violence would
be there if you pulled out the thing
that stops it even corrupt terrible cops
prevent violence by virtue of the fact
that when violence happens cops get
called and the even the terrible ones
are you know maybe the most frightening
ones to encounter so that's right and
and once again here we have an emotional
ploy you don't think we should defend
the police what are you against public
transportation you don't think we should
defund the police what are you against
accessible food programs how dare you I
don't think people should eat you don't
think people should be able to get to
their jobs and their families if they
can't pay for it how dare you sir
it's a it's an attack on your values
yeah and it is enough to drive a systems
thinker insane because these things
aren't hooked up it's not like a blue
Lego you can swap out for a red one it's
you know it's something totally
different so yeah that the apples one I
do want to go back and say bad apples
spoil the bunch about to spoiled a bunch
that is actually the original sentiment
you know almost every time I hear bad
apples invoked it is invoked in a way
that is incoherent right to say well
it's not that the police are bad it's
a few bad apples suggest that those
apples haven't tainted anything else
here at least they've got that right
right the whole idea is well if you
think the bunch is okay you don't
understand the nature of bad apples they
care and the whole thing about now the
question is is it does that apply to
things like policing Yeah right and it's
an interesting question yeah I mean and
I I think it would be impossible for
there not to be some effect of having a
corrupt policeman in your midst if you
are even if the rest of the police are
not corrupt that corruption does have an
insidious spreading effect yeah well and
let's just say one of the things that
we're learning relatively late in our
understanding of what human beings are
and how they function is how many things
are contagious including things like
happiness you know you walk into a room
with a dour look on your face and it
actually spreads you walk into a room
with a smile on your face it spreads and
it actually changes the circuitry
it changes your understanding of your
own mental state which is why guys on
the make are so fond of telling women
they should smile more because the point
is if you can get a woman to smile even
by tricking her into doing it she'll
think she likes you better than she
actually does so anyway all of the great
dating advice from Brett Weinstein sorry
no this is I mean this is a point that
we should come back to you know some
more time too but absolutely but just
the number of things that are contagious
that are now contagious over the
internet across a notion that make for a
completely incoherent narrative where
suddenly you know police violence
happens here in a place where police
violence may be exceedingly rare yet by
virtue of the fact that here seems like
it encompasses everybody who has a
conversation in a language you can
understand so back to our earlier point
about losing our minds yeah right okay
let's see this is a little hard to read
sorry it may take a while to comprehend
your role and racist problems but keep
in mind that people are dying while they
wait for you and then it attributes this
quote to someone named Jenn Winston of
black lives matter
this is a claim that is now simply being
trotted out a lot of the claims and
white fragility in the book that is
untestable because your world your role
in racist systems is so vague
you know what systems are racist what
makes them racist and what does your
role that it is it is untestable and so
we are told and I think actually no one
of these maybe I didn't include because
the picture was bad advises that you
know you can't just be not racist you
must be anti-racist and this speaks
exactly to some of what you and John
McWhorter we're talking about it is the
quote/unquote anti-racist movement that
is their religious movement just and
it's it it shows that they're good at PR
right an tyfa if you're anti-fascist
yeah well then if you're anti
anti-fascist you must be pro-fascist if
you're anti anti racist you must be pro
racist and of course that's not actually
true that disagreeing with these
movements makes you the thing that they
claim to be fighting against because
it's really easy to be claimed to be
fighting against something well I think
we need to start engaging the idea that
these are not terms and claims they are
moves just moves yeah they are moves
this is a system and if you try to
navigate by intuition you will find
yourself it spawn there's no escaping it
yeah so i remember actually the first
time i heard the term anti-racist
it was totally positive okay first time
i heard it was in the four o'clock
meeting at evergreen where violence
nearly broke out several times and
several the first day of the protests
that were turning into us calling for my
head i decided to go to the meeting they
complained about the fact that I was
there because what a guy who thought he
was in danger come to a meeting like
this now of course I hadn't felt that I
was in danger until that meeting but in
any case I was there and several
extremely courageous students stood up
to defend me including several students
of color right your students meizu me
felt it imperative that they speak on my
behalf which i still
honored by their willingness to confront
a very angry mob when in fact they would
be targeted for doing so a couple of
like small bodied women of color yeah
like you know people who could easily
have been at physical risk even if other
people weren't and one such woman stood
up in that meeting that tape exists you
can look at Benjamin voices
documentation of that meeting and you
can see her defending me and she says
not only is he not racist
he's anti-racist and I heard her say
that I thought I'd never thought to use
that term never heard it but what a
lovely thing for someone to say about
you right and now I feel about it
exactly as I feel about feminism there
was a time when I would have said I was
a feminist because I thought what
feminism meant was equal opportunity for
women and of course I'm for that
but obviously feminists frankly the
National Organization for Women thought
enough of you to give you an award to
that effect back when you were fighting
both racism and misogyny on the campus
of Penn the first college that you went
to yep
but you know you sign up for these
things I'm not even sure when feminism
became a term that I couldn't get behind
but at some point I was like no way
right that's not their way of went off
the rails in the 90s again a topic for
many other conversations right but my
point is there's no you can't even just
navigate there's no basis to navigate
other than I want you to write down the
definition I'm not signing onto any word
you can't define um which you know is
all I want a stable definition that I
can refer back to you so I can't just
say oh no that's not what we ever met
yep yeah sorry okay here we go this is
this is what I call it don't hurt me
well this is a business that's put up as
many of these as as they possibly can
hoping presumably though they don't get
vandalized now this isn't a part of
Portland that hasn't been vandalized yet
but but one never knows and just a
close-up on one of these is if you are a
person who believes in love justice
integrity and equity for all people then
you know that this work is
negotiable says Leila F Saad again black
lives matter so once again we are being
told and we cash did we hear this at
Evergreen as well yeah if you do not
sign on not only to our conclusion but
also our methods and everything about
what we are doing and how we are
intending to accomplish it then in this
case you do not believe in love justice
integrity equity for all knows those
cannot be values that you hold if you do
not follow us in lockstep and the bodies
in that one are buried under the word
this this is what work this work you
signed on to this work yes yeah just
okay so here we're nearing the end of
these commit to being anti-racist and
there's a QR code and I'm going to show
you what happens when you link on that
QR code when we get to the very end of
these which is just a couple more commit
to being anti-racist another one donate
put your money where your mouth is same
QR code egos the same place and before I
show you where that goes which is
basically it's gonna show you how you
can put your money where your mouth this
you know thirty dollars for a family
meal how dare you why don't you put your
money to these now I'm that's I'm
exaggerating but your to your point
earlier one final image that I took on
the streets of Oklahoma village in
Portland today Stonewall was a riot
started by black and Latin X trans women
bang bang bang
that seems like an outlier the heck is
that doing yeah right is that done s so
suck if you could take down my screen
for a minute while I find what happens
to what happens when we click through on
that Kira code here we are okay so Zack
let's pull this back up it's a compiled
list of donation resources that are
supposedly you know include providing
bail money among other things for people
who have been taken in and you know
otherwise these all kind of sound right
except LGBTQ specific organization what
does that have to do with black lives
matter well let's just scroll down a
little bit and we very quickly find
okay so black lives matter good black
trans travel fund what what does what is
that and then a mutual aid project
developed in order to help provide black
trans transgender women with the
financial resources need to be able to
self-determine say for alternatives to
travel so this isn't about black people
it's about black transgender people and
it's not even about black transgender
people
it's about black trans women so this is
a point that I'm sure we will return to
because this is becoming really a little
terrifying about the connection here but
let me just that's not that's hardly the
only trans thing on this list and I say
this you know as someone as I've made
really clear so many times we have trans
friends we had trans students transit
rail transit rare this is being
politicized and and is tearing down a
lot of the important protections in
society so we have the trans women of
color collective the trans justice
funding project and there are a couple
more up there that I oh and then you
know this one's Honorable Organization
the SPLC the Southern Poverty Law Center
which has become quite quite captured
[Music]